[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici la relance de la culture de l'p
passe par les laboratoires du P de des
plantes à Saint-Pierre depuis une
douzaine d'années maintenant les
chercheurs et techniciens du CAD ont
entrepris un long et patient travail
d'assaainissement des semences des trois
principales variétés locales d'ail le
tir rouge le vaca et le gros bleu on est
vraiment au tout début de la de la
séquence d'assaainissement donc qui
consiste à éliminer des virus présents
sur l'ail qui sont deux virus majeurs
l'ydv le
LYSV et là donc on part de matériel qui
est contaminé donc des bulbes d'ail avec
des cailleux d'ail qui sont contaminés
par ces virus euh et donc on va par des
techniques de culture de meristè essayer
d'éliminer ces virus et donc c'est ce
que l'on fait aujourd'hui on fait dans
un premier temps on retire le germe de
du cailleux et à partir de ce germe on
va aller chercher le mistè donc qui est
cette zone indemme de virus qu'on va
trouver sur chaque sur chaque caillou
l'opération est minutieuse et délicate à
l'aide d'un scalpel Jérémy Ramin prélève
avec précision l'extrémité du bourgeon
de la gousse d'ail là je suis en train
de préparer enlever le germe le dégager
pour pouvoir ensuite prélever le mistam
qui se trouve à l'intérieur faut quand
même être précis il y a une façon
préparé de manière à pouvoir avoir une
base une base carrée de préférence pour
qu'une fois être sous la Hute on puisse
la manipuler de la bonne façon ce que
l'on voit là c'est la la pointe du
scalpel et ici c'est le donc le le mistè
qui fait qui fait à peu près 0,3 03 mm
qui est qui est ici qui va être déposé
donc sur le milieu de culture mise en
culture le mistè va alors se développer
in vitro pendant plusieurs semaines donc
ça va redonner un microbul donc qui va
se développer donc pour au final donner
un Bub complet qu'on pourra acclimater
une vivo faudra encore des années avant
d'avoir un Bub de bonne taille et donc
de pouvoir l'utiliser
correctement ces différentes étapes en
laboratoire permettent ainsi d'obtenir
des premières semement saines indemn de
virus et de maladies une phase
indispensable dans le plan de relance de
la filière IPI c'est la première phase
c'est la la vraiment le départ de la de
la toute la production de semence qui va
suivre derrière C c'est c'est une une
phase complètement essentielle à toute
une toute la filière toute la la relance
de la filière de la production d'il à la
Réunion mais ailleurs puisque c'est des
techniques qui sont appliquées partout
dans dans le
[Musique]
monde acteur de la relance de la
production d'ail runionné le CAD a
entrepris depuis 2002 de produire des
semences assaignies de trois variétés
locales le gros bleu le vacois et le
tiouge après une phase de multiplication
en laboratoire à partir de mer stem les
gous d'en sont plantés en pleine terre
mais bien à l'abri sous dessert là ce
que je fais ben je trie les plus jolis
caillux parce que le plus gros caillux
justement vont faire les plus jolis
Bubles et les plus petits cailleux bon
ce sont des caillux qui qui vont faire
bien sûr des plus petits bulpes et c'est
pas intéressant donc on les élimine on
les élimine mais la BASF en fin de
compte c'est pour avoir des des lignes
droites régulier donc pour avoir un gen
de gabarit tout simplement donc là les
les plus belles gousses que monsieurap
dit à sélectionner donc à fait un trier
hein euh sont mis en terre et euh c'est
quelle variété ça c'est le tiro c'est le
VOA là ce qu'on va planter dans cette
dans cette SRE il y a deux variétés le
variété vacoa et le variété gros bleu le
but c'est de multiplier les semences à à
partir des des semences assaignies hein
justement pour avoir d'autres semences
pour la la continuité pour les pour les
plateurs parallèlement à la
multiplication de ces semences saines
les techniciens du CAD cultivent avec
soin une collection originale de
plusieurs variétés d'ail aujourd'hui on
récolle l'ail de collection par qu'
arrivé à maturité donc c'est la bonne
période a une trentaine de variétés
c'est l'il qui vient de différents pays
donc nous garde ça chaque année pour
pour replter après mais il y a des
variétés qui sont bien adaptées il y a
les variétés qu'on cultive depuis
longtemps ici a le gros bleu le qui
et tu rouge ce sont des variétés que ça
fait P enc cultive et ce sont des
variétés qui sont déjà passées par un
cycle d'assainissement et qui sont
proposés aux professionnels mais là
c'est c'est de variétés qui sont en
phase justement d'amélioration euh pour
voir justement leur comportement leur
productivité leur adaptation conditions
de culture locale euh pour voir comment
si on peut les utiliser plus tard quoi
après ça c'est le le chercheur d'aurs
qui va décider de de l'intérêt de de
garder telle ou telle variété mais nous
notre rô là c'est de conserver donc c
variété de cette collection sur sur le
terrain donc année après année donc de
de replanter pour pour garder un bon
[Musique]
stock